shoko iyeri is the most underrated
character introduced to Kaizen in the
entire series there are only three
Sorcerers who've been shown to heal
someone else by using reverse curse
technique the first is sukuna who's
arguably the greatest Sorcerer of all
time the second is Utah who has nearly
unlimited curse energy and the final
person is shoko herself in season 2 we
see shoko in her younger days when she
was Gojo's classmate and her talent for
reverse curse technique was so valuable
that the school never sent her on
dangerous missions after graduating from
Jiu Jitsu High she then studied to
become a doctor and according to Volume
2 she obtained her doctor's license in
only a couple of years but it was partly
thanks to her cheating